has herpes this is evidence
a female privilege
only a woman could go into a store like
this and spread her legs yeah show it to
me yeah so funny when women find out i
like salsa they like
oh everywhere yeah the women find out
then they're like so do you like bachata
and i'm like no that she's disgusting
and he's like yo their hearts break of
course and then i i dig the dagger even
deeper i'm like it don't [__] sucks
you did that out there yeah yeah i do i
don't give a [__] bro
i don't give a [__] no you don't you
don't like no no no
no no turn that [__] off
i used to be like that
oh yeah i'm not gonna go get out of my
way to listen to
today
you know i mean i'm not going to go out
of my way to listen to that but there's
some there's some
there's some beats that i'm like aye aye
[Music]
ow mean the same beat they've been
making for a hundred years
so you don't wait you don't bachata you
don't [__] with it at all no
at all turn that [__] off okay
i'll [__] with it
you don't know what's happening
you know what's happening is preach
recently got a new job he's an
ambassador for inclusivity for one of
the organizations so now he has to get
up on here and spew his [__] every
single day so all the time that you
think oh my god no it's not it's his job
he's getting paid to do this what are
you talking about when you ask remember
you guys are talking about like
so much [__]
what's the name of your organization you
deserve to know the truth
i never compromise just for you guys
what are you talking about you guys
suspect that we're shilling it's not me
there's apple and preach will the and
preach part
somebody somebody took the aim part and
put some dineros
that's some [__] right there
that is the worst
[__] you've ever said hey check
check the bank accounts all right
yeah check the bank accounts take the
bank check them see who who actually
have
[__] hey i'm just saying i don't know
you got a brand new house i don't know
how you pay for that oh good that's how
we do it we're lying what do you mean
all right cool alba has herpes
let's just [__] that
i should have said
watch this but he definitely got on you
all right let's play it
what was that what do you mean
what you mean get the [__] out
he didn't think i noticed
oh that feels good
yeah
if it's there i'm looking
say i said it
i said it if it's there i'm looking i'm
not gonna stare
but it's possible that i might glance
you have a whole skirt on this [__] you
don't you you don't like when
[__] man spread and then you
got your thing
and it's fun it's really fun i don't
care
if it's there i might glance yep i'm not
gonna stare but i might glance i'm
talking about coochie boobies camel toes
anything i'm gonna tell you right now
i'll glance oh yeah that's why most of
the time i wear shades yeah
yeah
i glance
[__] yeah if it's there pop it
i'm not gonna try to make you feel
uncomfortable about it but if it's there
it's in his face you know what the [__]
you doing and you're filming too all
right
that's bait and you filming too that's
bait
you baited him yay
yeah
i'm looking
[__] y'all here i want to see the pump
[__] up
he's you know damn where his face is at
you know damn
he didn't think i noticed
you know damn well what the [__] he was
doing
yeah
you have made a decision
you've made a decision
to spread your legs
you have said open sesame you have
gotten mad when i went into the vault
you have invited the hundred thieves and
then you have opened the door they are
not thieves they are guests
we are going to talk about it hey guess
what when you have in a car and you park
your car and you unlock your doors what
does the police do they give you a
ticket
yeah
you're going to jail
you're going to jail pay off that's you
with your doors open
unlock your
for what reason you're trying to cause
you know damn well if a woman was there
she would have looked too but a man said
come on lady you went into that place
and look look at her laugh did you
notice
she got a towel on her left what do you
think the towel is for yeah that feels
so good what do you think the towel
but then you're going to put them on
tick-tock to that knobby we're not doing
that he looking i'm glad this
[__] looked [__] yo listen
[__] want to post a first trap
get mad when folks are thirsty excuse me
y'all [__] out there having
whole lemonade stand uh worrying about
oh [__] pulling up to have some
lemonade [__] stop selling [__] you
started a fight
he called the firefighter i sell it
you open your legs in front of him
he glanced and noticed like oh my dick
he gave you a towel for a reason hey
[__] start fires worried about
the smoke oh there's too much smoke
don't start a fire then that's it hey do
you want to get mad at a man
knowing damn well a woman would have
done the same thing because every woman
in the comment section right now said i
would have glenn said her [__] too so
you got a she got a whole skirt
she got a whole skirt with her legs open
[__]
and you gonna get mad at me all you
[__] when it's wintertime when
when october comes on ain't you
[__] glancing at [__] dick
prince and grey pants
huh
yeah you making whole memes about that
[__]
you glancing over
dick prince oh dick prince season
there's a season did print in gray
jogging pants has a season
and then you worried about that no
no
glance my dude listen you plans you an
attention [__] and it's okay glance my
dude but don't make other people out to
be creepy
can we take a second to appreciate let's
take five no no let's take a this is
evidence a female privilege huh
only a woman could go into a store like
this
with her whole underwear yeah and spread
her legs yeah show it to the employees
and then get
talked to them like they're the crazy
ones
if i sow my underwear in any place
any place
you know they're going to call the
police how quickly
the internet lose their mind because a
dude out here showing dick and balls or
the underwear sprint his legs no that's
if we that's if that's if we gonna
that's if we assume that you're wearing
any pennies at all
okay which judging by how you look for
attention hey
okay
listen
listen to me
it's crazy right no it's crazy because
like they can go out there and be creepy
so let me go let me go let me go out
here and just go i'm gonna go back to
what i said
i'm glancing
i'm not glancing i'm staring see movie
premiere hey i'm looking hey listen if
you hey black panther too let's go if
you're going out there and you're you're
being a whole meat market i'm looking at
the meat stand yeah i'm looking at the
meat my vision's sturdy vibranium keep
on looking
stop no you want to show your titties
i'll look i look
that's fine no no it's not like i'm
walking by or some [__] [__] you came
to my workplace spread your legs tell me
work on my calves
how am i not going to take that as an
invitation
get my mom and fedora doesn't understand
go get your mom
this is the same girl
i know not listen
this is her boo boo b
baby you're doing a whole much i'm
looking at the airport
i'm looking at the airport listen okay
okay bruh bruh you came girl girl i am
not mad at you no ma'am
you want us to look
and it's fine
we looking
next subject it's just funny that you
can do that a guy that does that we call
that ass
go to a [__]
workplace
and just expose your genitals as a woman
and then make the dude look creepy for
looking at what you exposed it remind me
of the woman who said you are projecting
your sexuality onto me no [__] you
projected your genitals onto my eyesight
it's not the other way around
i didn't leave the home and say who
could i creep on no you spread your legs
for me
what that's what you're talking about
what you're doing right there is called
exhibitionism
yep you like to show your [__] yup and
it's fine
you call that we call him
hold on we call hold on we call that
exit positionism when it's a man
you just turn strapping and that's okay
right you see how [__] up it is
remember when we were like back in the
80s and the 90s right we were talking
about creepy men in parks wearing trans
coats and going like this you
this shoe yep this shoe but now with
social media we call that
thirst trapping no
you're the same dudes
you're the same dude in the dude in the
park
that's you
that's you it's thirst trap so it's okay
no that's you that is you
the same ammo you expose yourself unto
people you're actually worse than the
dude in the park back in the 90s because
the dude in the park back in the night
would be like he knew and he left i need
you and he knew what the [__] he was
doing you
you're doing this
yeah ew you looking yup that's you
you're worse in almost any workplace
this would be considered
sexual
yeah
any workplace yeah sexual harassment
yeah but hey not only is it not in this
case because she is she she is she yeah
but on tick-tock
but on tick-tock it's not sexual
anything it's just which sounds like a
cool pokemon but it's true she is she
so it's not
but if she wasn't he
this would be a different thing
not only is it not a criminal thing
she can monetize it and make money think
about that
think about that and you don't think
that women
think about it yeah so it is what it is
it is what it is
right you got your titties popping out
your shirt
that's okay we all like milk poop it up
but don't get mad at us when we get a
little bit calcium deficient you feel me
good